Camboya es la penúltima parada del viaje
Express del presidente estadounidense en
el centro de los debates La amenaza
nuclear norcoreana pero también Taiwán y
China un preludio de la reunión entre
dubaidan Valley dentro de unos días en
el marco del g20 otro tema importante el
estancamiento de la crisis en yanmark el
líder de la junta no fue invitado por
segundo año consecutivo una ausencia que
delata la falta de avances en las
conversaciones para resolver la crisis
muchos líderes asiáticos y el secretario
general de la ONU afirman que la junta
no ha cumplido sus objetivos de
restablecer la paz
de violencia el uso desproporcionado de
la fuerza y la terrible situación de los
Derechos Humanos en mi al mar los
ataques indiscriminados contra civiles
pueden constituir crímenes de guerra
según el derecho internacional
este año la asociación de Naciones del
sur está Asia chico va más allá los
líderes quieren involucrar los grupos de
oposición de myanmar en el proceso de
paz esto ha provocado La era de la junta
gobernante que considera sus opositores
como terroristas las organizaciones
humanitarias también denuncian las
acciones de la junta
Por las luchas geopolíticas entre
Estados Unidos y China sobre la cuestión
de myanmar pero los dirigentes se
olvidan de que miles de personas han
perdido la vida a manos de esta junta
diabólica Y seguirán perdiendola
mientras las sean siga paralizada
la asea no es conocida por sus posturas
divisivas pero este año se está
endureciendo e incluso se está
considerando excluir a los
representantes de myanmar por completo
si la situación lo justifica